si la parole est à monsieur philippe
goujon monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'intérieur du
balla chassés par les guerres où la
misère c'est par dizaines de milliers
que des migrants désemparé exploités par
des passeurs sans scrupules tentent de
rejoindre nos côtés de traverser les
frontières france italie grande bretagne
allemagne accueillant 80% des réfugiés
de toute l'europe
6e cible migratoires au monde la france
a connu un doublement des demandes
d'asile devenu la principale source
d'arrivée clandestins puisque alors que
75 % des demandes sont rejetées
seul 1% des déboutés et effectivement
éloignés comment faire face un tel
afflux quand en une seule semaine c'est
près de 15 100 clandestins interpellés
rien que dans les alpes maritimes
certainement pas en ouvrant un centre
d'accueil pour migrants comme l'exigent
la maire de paris dont le seul effet
sera un appel d'air migratoire sans
précédent at autant de logements
d'emplois d'allocations à distribuer
alors monsieur le ministre allez vous
céder à la pression d'anne hidalgo et
que sa majorité d'ouvrir un sangatte bis
en plein paris ou suivrez-vous plutôt la
cour des comptes qui préconise
l'expulsion des déboutés plutôt que des
quotas instaurés vous un blocus
migratoire favoriserait vous une
harmonisation européenne du droit
d'asile refondre et vous schengen
abandonnerez vous dans votre réforme de
l'asile les nouvelles facilités de
regroupement familial renforçant
l'attractivité migratoires dans notre
pays
si la france a vocation à sauver des
vies en perdition en méditerranée elle
doit avant tout dissuader les migrants
de partir vers l'europe au waterloo
morale dénoncée par les verts
n'ajoutez pas monsieur le ministre une
bérézina migratoires pour la france
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls le président avant
de répondre à monsieur philippe goujon
député de paris permettrait mois
puisqu'elle va quitter le gouvernement
dans quelques heures pour se consacrer à
la campagne électorale dans une grande
région de sud de rendre hommage à carole
delga pour le travail qu'elle a eu
l'occasion de le faire ne pouvons pas
m'exprimer après je voulais le faire
avec votre permission je vais je vais
répondre
je vais répondre à philippe goujon
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous
avez pu constater que je suis candidat
un endroit beaucoup moins éloignés que
carole delga et bien sûr je ne manquerai
pas des trophées et dont claude
bartolone ce soir engagé dans une autre
campagne
je vais essayer de réfléchir mais je
j'ai tout le temps
monsieur bouchons
et vous plaît allez monsieur goujon
comme monsieur guibal tout à l'heure
vous poser une question sur un sujet
particulièrement difficile et complexe
annick girardin a déjà donné un certain
nombre d'éléments mais c'est vrai que
l'afflux d'émigrants pose à l'europe et
à schengen des questions sans précédent
ces questions sont en train d'être
traités actuellement dans un conseil
j'aille justice affaires intérieures
avec la présence bien sûr c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'est pas là de
bernard cazeneuve mais cela pose pour
l'europe et pour les états membres de
schengen des questions sur leur capacité
à faire face en mettant des mécanismes
de solidarité et en assurant un contrôle
des flux à l'arrivée la france et vous
le savez d'abord un pays de transit
une part majoritaire des migrants ne
cherche pas à s'y installer
il y a néanmoins qui peut l'ignorer des
points de fixation sur lesquels il faut
intervenir
c'est vrai du côté de menton c'est vrai
à calais où nous menons une action
particulièrement vigoureuse
c'est le cas à paris le gouvernement
annoncera ce mercredi des mesures par la
voix de bernard cazeneuve permettant
d'éviter que le se forment des
campements précaires qui sont indignes
de notre pays et qui pose des problèmes
sanitaires et de sécurité
faut-il mettre en place c'est votre
question des centres d'accueil pour
migrants et essayons de traiter ces
sujets sans polémique
non non car les règles actuelles sont
claires les personnes qui ont besoin
d'une protection ont accès à des
solutions d'hébergement centre d'accueil
de demandeurs d'asile hébergement
d'urgence les capacités doivent être
adaptées aux besoins et c'est au coeur
du plan gouvernemental qui sera donc
présenté demain mais cela doit se faire
dans le cadre existant
la réforme de l'asile que vous allez
discuter porté ici par madame le
rapporteur madame sandrine mazetier a
précisément pour objectif de laurent de
rend l'accès à l'hébergement plus fluide
et mieux réparties sur le territoire et
les autres migrants
ceux qui ne sont pas réfugiés ceux qui
ne répondent pas à ce droit fondamental
qu'est le droit d'asile n'ont pas
vocation à rester en france
ils doivent être donc reconduit à la
frontière des progrès peuvent être faits
sur les est de retour des renforts sont
possibles bien sûr nous l'avons déjà
fait pour le sud ou à calais pour
utiliser au mieux les dispositifs
existants et mieux faire travailler les
services ensemble enfin et madame annick
girardin le rappeler je crois avec
beaucoup de force
laurent fabius le souligne régulièrement
il faut une politique en direction des
pays d'afrique dans ces migrants
économiques de plus en plus nombreux
sont originaires
et cette politique portée notamment par
l'union européenne doit être beaucoup
plus ambitieuse et prendre en compte le
problème de l'émigration qui est aussi
un problème de développement
bref sur toutes ces questions la bonne
réponse est à la fois de prévoir des
dispositifs efficaces d'accueil et
d'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile est
une politique de très grande fermeté
contre l'immigration irrégulière
l'évacuation des campements se
poursuivra dans le respect des droits
des migrants avec des solutions
d'hébergement mais sans céder à la
menace d'un certain nombre de personnes
qui jouent un rôle particulièrement
dangereux et qui mettent en danger les
migrants eux mêmes les discussions au
niveau européen doivent à présent
aboutir il en va de l'avenir même de
l'espace de schengen et de notre
capacité à gérer correctement
humainement c'est crise fermeté et
humanité responsabilité et justice
voilà la politique du gouvernement merci
monsieur le premier ministre la parole
est à mme madame odile saugues